cool thank you so hello and welcome to
our talk about
um a machine learning life cycle for NDP
classification in e-commerce
um
next slide
okay
um before we give you our agenda let's
introduce ourselves
to BS um is stand next to me he's been
working for a dealer idiano now since
three years
a senior ml engineer my name is Gunner
I've been with idiano for eight years
now and also work as an ml engineer
uh that's our agenda
um first we give your brief uh overview
of idiolo's a company and some key facts
but only for short
and then we introduce our machine
learning classification background yeah
that you know in which context we uh we
are working
um continuing with our machine learning
life cycle how we think it is which
steps we implement
from data to model and deployment
then we'll continue with some ml Ops so
we
implemented our solution to a
self-contained cluster and we created
the solution to the cloud how we did it
uh which things we learned we give you
some takeaways
and hopefully have enough time for your
question and give your answer
here on site or from remote
okay
short some key facts about idiallo we
are accompanying about 20 years now
experience in e-commerce
um we are quite International so over a
thousand employees working we are based
in Berlin
uh so yeah people from over 40 countries
um the data we do our price comparison
uh are from 50 000 online shops so quite
a big set
And We Gather it over 500 million online
offers
for 2 million online products so that's
uh some benchmarks about idialis
data and the classification background
that we want to talk about is
you can imagine like this so on the one
side you have the shops here on the left
uh there are big shops and small shops
medium-sized shops uh and from a big
bunch of uh e-commerce segments yeah
nearly all e-commerce segments uh
deliver us
um their data their show at their offers
that's on the one side and on the other
side there's the idealo category
structure yeah it's like a category 3
with about 2 000 product categories yeah
so full segment
and each product category has a list of
or a set of product types that's
something like a sub category yeah or
imagine it's a tech yeah and there uh
the system has over 25 000
um product types so 25 000 tax yeah
and
the task is to the assignment of all the
offers from the shop yeah the import
continuously through our idiallo
category system and this is done via
classification
next slide okay
um
if you look at the single offer yeah for
instance a sneaker like this yeah so an
individual offer uh the task looks like
this yeah the offer is a
well-defined set of metadata
an image a title a short description
text along a description text it has a
price manufacturer uh category given by
the shop yeah
and
of course a bunch of text data and we
generate out of this text Data uh some
relevant text features
and you pause use a support Vector
machine applying on this text feature to
do our product category classification
and for the product types
um we use deep learning model
multi-layer pods preset drone but that's
only to have an idea of what in which
context we are talking
and that's just a brave brief overview
of our classification task
and
One Step uh
higher or on the on on a conceptual view
this classification task is
embedded in our machine learning life
cycle yeah
and
the machine learning life cycle I guess
most of you know it's like a theoretical
concept
that describes the continuous sequence
of repetitable steps that brings the
data to a productive model yeah and how
we think the life cycle and which Dems
steps are important and how we
implemented it will be part of
um the next sections
so in short life cycle consists of these
four steps starting with data collection
continue model building model training
then model Aviation
and last but not least we classifier
deployment
and I would like now to introduce you
what's behind each individual step
so first
data collection
uh it's clear every machine learning
model is based on data
the data that we use is based on
manually maintained product offers so
really manually created data and out of
this we generate our data for the next
steps and the data is in our data Lake
we use Athena queries to get already
data sets and we store each data set
on external storage device with a
version number
and
to ensure that we can repeat experiments
at any time on the same data set
next step is training or model building
here
and as already mentioned we only use
Text data for our classifiers this means
that
the pre-processing and filtering on the
text Data
must be equal between training time and
inference when the models in deployment
yeah so this has to be short and short
and has to be also keep in mind
and
we also generate each model that we
generate has a version and for us it was
good practice that version of the uh
data we use and the model version are
they match together with same
identifiers
um
after model building we do a model
aggregation so
and this is based on the test data that
we get from from the data collection
step in Step One
uh that's also pulled from the data Lake
the test data and for
the validation of a model so every model
that is built was goes through a
validation process but this we keep
quite simple just a simple indicator on
model F1 score
and if the fund score of the model is
above a certain threshold then we say
okay that's a valid model and if not
then we keep the model back but however
uh if the in our case we have a 2000
class
ification problem or 25 000 class
uh classification problem there are a
lot of opportunities where how to
evaluate the model and we store all the
data that we generate during evaluation
so F1 score Precision recall accuracy
for every single class for every single
product type and even for different
levels of uh of
[Music]
um
of thresholds of confidence
and so there's a real big amount of data
that we generate through evaluation and
we store all the data as Json on on
external storage but also on on our data
Lake
um last but not least classify
deployment
as already mentioned when validate check
has was valid uh the model is ready for
deployment
but there are a few boundary conditions
that has to be kept in mind yeah so the
model must be uh sure for or must uh
guarantee scalability yeah in case of
different fluctuations in traffic a
model can outscale uh the the instant
that analyzes it and so scalability is
quite important during deployment
although sometimes of course something
unexpected here the model doesn't uh
doesn't run for some cases yeah in this
case
uh
uh immediately you have to roll back or
we have to roll back in our case uh to a
stable version yeah and last but not
least
cost efficiency during deployment
something that
is quite important if you go to the
cloud
um last but not least monitoring uh this
is quite an essential Point uh during
life cycle
to ensure stability of every uh process
step yeah and monitoring can be done
during different periods monthly
monitoring weekly hourly even minutely
monitoring
and on the other side
every single step can be monitored yeah
there are data Matrix during data
collection number samples number classes
model metrics already mentioned but last
not least of course also the operational
metrics during classifier deployment uh
very important if you went online with
your model
and especially after deployment it's
quite important to ensure that the model
can stand the incoming traffic
um
in our case where does this graphic I
mentioned where does it come from so you
can see here the structure of a kind of
structure of our components in the
middle there's our team space
via mixed team of kotlin developers we
are machine learning Engineers so we are
responsible for declassifiers but also
for kotlin components yeah and there's
outer space so there's a event of
architecture and there comes traffic in
their ghost traffic house but the
traffic goes through our system
and the responsibility of our team is to
ensure that the traffic uh goes smooth
and stable through our system and that's
why it's necessary to monitor uh all the
traffic during after deployment and the
time on and the traffic in our case
means so just to mention the numbers up
to 2 billion offers per week
and
from lifecycle to operations to be able
to tell you something about this
yeah
so um when we started our journey we use
the hybrid solution that means
um we did our training and our
continuous training on a cloud and the
service deployment and CCI CC cicd was
done on a self-contained kubernetes
service at from edialo as you see here
just at the beginning we splitted our
life cycle in different components and
there we were able to develop each
complement independently
um
the services
we are deployed via cdk the search
vehicle pipelines and the service itself
was deployed by using our workflow and
hand packages and so when we change
something in the code then we run our
automatic
deployment pipeline we do unit testing
integration testing
and use argue workflow for the pipeline
um so in that case we trained each to
week a new model it means this is
triggered that in the pipelines are
triggered the model is trading when the
training was finished we store
everything the data and the model on S3
bucket
which are corresponding to timestamps
and Views these timestamps as identifier
and then on the kubernetes side I've
Implement an Argo con job which looks
each morning or text each morning if
there is a new model and if there's a
new model
then we write this identifier in the
configuration file which is in the
service repo we push it to the service
variable and this triggers the our
workflow and then the service knows
which model it should be deployed and I
use hand packaging for the deployment
and our CDs does the roll out for us
that means it does a safe deployment
lifeless probes and so on and so on and
the kubernetes
Services they are connected to our
monitoring we use grafana and kibana for
the locks and for the metrics and we
also tracked the experiment's
performance with mflow but we quite
early found out that mfloat does not
fulfill all our needs so as Gunner said
we have to store more detailed
evaluation metrics and Json files and
also the version photos
um yeah
so um with this early solution uh we had
very good experiences especially rcd
provides us a very intuitive user
interface but the topic of Argos that it
takes some time to get used with
workflow into argosity because of all
the yaml files and all the AMU
configuration but we were very lucky
that we had a team member which was from
the kotlin part which were used very
used to Argos ID and we've learned a lot
from him and we had also a very
supportive operations team which won the
kubernetes cluster and helped us with
the initial initializations
[Music]
um
yeah when we run our services then
um we have seen that the memory demand
of classifier can increase drastically
during the operation that's in our
case because
um we allow different kind of batch
sizes and then the traffic increase it
can be that the batteries get really
high and since we use support Vector
machine which is has a huge sparse
feature and this somehow has to unfold
to a dense feature uh we frequently run
out of memory and this was after the
safe deployment so in production this
can be really a mess so we learned that
we have to test our memory beforehand
and our the memory demand of our
services under
um different operations mode under the
full load and also under normal
operation mode
we also found out that during the
versioning of our data in the simplistic
way is for us easier than handle large
databases feature stores or ml flow
especially when afterwards we had to
take a look at the json's file so if we
have some did some experiences
um this like easy solution was for us
gave us the best flexibility to
accessing the data and to play around
with the data
um yeah when our company decided that we
want to move into the cloud uh we
changed we had only changed our model
deployment from kubernetes to sagemaker
we benefited from the fact that we had
separated all the components of the
lifecycle
and we were also thinking and doing like
lift the shift of the deployment to eks
Cluster from Amazon because uh the other
half of our two team has to go to the
eks cluster with their kotlin services
but we decided to say stay in the same
ecosystem
um since also safe maker provides us
safe deployment and auto scaling
um to service providers a good solution
and we moved the cicd from our workflow
to GitHub actions
where the pipelines can be deployed via
cdk and all the roles and stuff and but
the classifier has to be deployed via
the sagemaker API and this can be done
from like the model training when a new
model arrives or it's trained and if we
change something in the service
implementations
so um experiment tracking was in change
from mflow to sagemic experience and we
attached the model registry from AWS but
we still have to store these Json files
because we didn't found a solution where
we can really have an overview of
fine-grained evaluation metrics and
finally monitoring we use the grafana
integration of cloudwatch Matrix and we
also use cloudwatch and cloudwatch
dashboards
um yep so in this slide
I would like to provide you a deeper
look into the model deployment because
this was for us an interesting case
um so from our experience we found
that's a good idea to separate
um the deployment of a new model from
the deployment of a new service
um
for that reason we have to ask the model
registry which was the last deployment
of the it was the last model which was
the last service and then you can start
a search micro deployment by defining a
model package you can then configure the
endpoint if you had the model package
choose the instance choose the
deployment strategy and we decided that
we need another another test of this
endpoint because we have to test against
this massive load we observed before and
that the models will not not crash when
we have large batch sizes another
positive way is to to like doing
additional test of the endpoint
um if it fails then we can remove all
the entries from the model registry we
have seen that if we do not that then
the model registry can be very cluttered
and we want to clean keep the model
version 3 clean
okay
um
one quite important point when moving
into cloud is coast
and
this almost is related to the instant
types that you use and to found our
certainly our optimal solution we did
some experiments to estimate runtime uh
on Coast for processing uh 2 billion
offers
and as you can see there is quite a wide
variety of instant types and some of
them do not fit in time and others do
not fit in codes but there is a very
there's a variety of instant types that
fit in time and course
and
this are yeah some some benchmarks we
did some Benchmark tests we did on three
on different instant types and here are
three examples and as you can see
um the uh ml R5 24x large
process has the best performance with
2.3 days processing two billion offers
but it's by far the it's most expensive
out of this yeah with 534 US dollars in
our case
uh a bit less performant with 2.27 days
is the M5 24x large but you can spend uh
uh uh safe uh one third of the money
yeah when using distance stunts
and in our case you have a limit of uh
of seven days so our product owner says
okay seven days should be our your
benchmark and in our case uh to we
decided to take the M5 4X large that
process the data in seven days
uh but uh only uh one third of the the
amount of the best performance instance
yeah so
uh to keep it short it's up to your
requirements up to your limits which
instance fits your needs best
um here's some lessons learned from our
immigration to the cloud
there's a small learning curve in
setting up Basics makeup pipeline
endpoints
um using infrastructure as code cdk or
for instance in our case this helped
really to automate our deployment
we have a friend of GitHub actions this
allowed us a painless CI CD integration
and uh we also uh think test classifier
performances for different instant types
make sense to keep your course in in the
cloud as low as possible and to be as uh
continuous with monitoring yeah
um in last minutes I would like to talk
about a monitoring of our training data
and service components from our point of
view
um is essential and you cannot start
early enough to monitor your services
and it's also important to check the
boards on a regular basis that means in
our team we check each morning
on our daily boards but I think it's
nothing new for you so let's move on so
when we when we are moving to the cloud
we use the corona integration of the
cloud Matrix that makes it really easy
and we have different Boards of
different degree of complexity for
example this is an example board which
is simple and interpretable for our team
lead and or for our po it shows how much
tenses we are using it shows the
throughput and it also shows if errors
are rising but for us developers the
operational Matrix are a little more
helpful to understand if our services
are working efficiently for example here
we see
um this is like a 16 core CPU service
and on the lower left
um only half nearly half of the services
used for computation
in an ideal case we would increase the
number of workers to make to run more
processes in parallel but you see also
that we are restricted in memory so 80
of the memory is used this is every time
a trade of you you have to deal when you
use
big models yep you know and also
interesting is for example the
prediction score where you can see model
drift and which gives a clue of how your
model is performing
um finally cloudwatch also allows you to
integrate a set maker pipeline status
metrics which gives you the top nice
overview of the status of your pipeline
and see it first place when something
went wrong here you see our trading
generator
had some problems uh a week ago and we
also track like like the training data
metrics the distributions of the classes
distributions of the offers for each
language and also like something like a
final scores
so uh yeah we've come to an end
um but I would like uh wouldn't let you
go to without sharing some some
takeaways of course yes these are very
personal and these are reflects very how
we work as a team but maybe you can find
yourself there and your experience there
um yep first thing is start monitoring
as fast as possible uh especially in
machine learning you have like Cycles
which are quite long so you have like a
Long training and if you want to observe
a matrix you need some measurements to
see a trend or to see if something
behaves wrong or bad and if you wait
until everything is ready then you have
to wait like a month to see if your
process is really working
um
and finally it was good to split our
life cycle into a different kind of
components which helps us in the
development in the testing phase and
also by moving through different
platforms and it's very essential that
you know the performance requirements of
your services
it helps you that they do not crash and
as we see even if you have a nice safe
deployment it can crash afterwards if
something happens uh the battery is
getting too big and finally if in our
case it's like we try to keep it simple
as possible so there are lots of
framework there a lot of solutions you
can attach but if you keep it simple it
helps you on testing it helps you on uh
issues
with dependencies uh yep and um last
point is um start morning start
monitoring your first puzzle that's
really the the most important thing for
us
um yeah thank you very much thank you
for your time thank you for spending uh
time with us in this talk
thanks
all right on to questions we're using
slider of course I forgot to mention
that there's already a bunch of
questions in here so I'll go through
these first and then if there's more
time
tent to the room did you consider
chaining multiple classifiers in a row
to reduce the number of possible classes
for example clothing classifier clothing
type classifier
we decided but decided against it yeah
you want to elaborate
um it's about propagating error during
the classifier
um when it was at first when we moved
from a German model to a multi-language
model we made some some experiments
where we want to find out um which is
the best solution and we can also like
have different classifiers for different
classes but especially with the Deep
learning we see that although there are
different kind of languages and there
are some in our case there are some
words like Brands which are in in in in
different languages and we increase thus
the the number of offers to train for
the classifier and if you split
everything in small classifiers then
each class of classifiers will be
trained with less amount of data and
that reduce accuracy in our perspective
here
nice thanks
um what kind of textual features are you
using for the svm bag of words
give IDF
so it's a classic back of words with
limit rating yeah can you tell us more
about how you load the data from so many
different shops which possibly differ
very much in data quality and structure
Etc
um there's a well-defined input
structure and there's something like
normalization so of course there's a
predefined uh Fields there the the shops
put in their data
but that's not in the scope of our team
so we take what what the the import team
gives us and I think we do the best with
it
how many persons work in your ml teams
um well at the general we have like a
core machine learning team which is a
lot of eight persons and our team is
we're like two machine learner and then
we have like uh six
six uh Java developer so
um we found it a good practice that the
the team would own the product which
uses machine learning has also
capability or persons who dealing with
machine learning so we had like the
proof of concept for normal internal
machine learning team and Victoria gave
to us and we are here to deploy it and
to also improve it
cool hope to answer the question yes why
do you need to retrain every two weeks
how do you decide whether the new model
is better okay
um we do need retraining because new
categories arise others are mixed
together so all this what happens with
categories and uh
it's like a like a a
good it was a good practice to have a
new model other every two weeks to keep
it uh actual yeah we made experience
with making this adaptive but then you
add complexity in your code something
can get wrong and two weeks was a good
trade-off
nice all right uh this question is for
me actually what was the motivation for
moving to Cloud native did you well you
have answered that did you achieve a
cost reduction
uh main motivation is scaling so um if
you have an own cluster and you want to
scale it's easier on a cloud and why is
it also easier because then we now we
have access to gpus for training and we
don't need them for this inference but
it's getting
cool when looking at cost versus
processing time did you also look into
changing code optimizations or other
languages
um not really because we we have as we
have a python stake and if we add like C
plus I came from the C plus area but if
there's no one else in the company who
doesn't know your language then it makes
doesn't make sense to have very
efficient code it's better to share code
and make it accessible
all right final questions how do you get
your labels for training
the labels for training so we got this
menu created products and the offers
match to uh to the products via
identifier and so the the product is
assigned to a category and so we got the
category for offer yeah and same with 50
tax so yeah but manually curated
yeah
that's maybe what what we like we have
all these content employees which meant
which create products which make this
Association for important stuff and we
can take our data from there and uh they
really helped us on our daily work out
all right thanks very much sorry we're
running out of time uh these two
gentlemen will be around so maybe you
can just talk in person for sorry for
all the questions we didn't get to
answer one more round of warm Applause
please for 200 years
[Applause]